[Music]
hey it's us
yeah now it's dark in here again you see
us what the [ __ ] is it is it this thing
maybe it is yeah okay
if you can hear any noise in the
background it's just the damn long crew
yeah
even though i don't know why they're
here today it's tuesday they do what
they want to do it doesn't have anything
to do with us i thought their day was
wednesday
i don't know what they do all right it
is tuesday today right
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
all right so um i think on the last show
what was the last show it's about using
uh shelf stable drive no we didn't the
last one was curry
curry okay yeah yeah yeah that's good
too all right um
this is uh this today's gonna be about
pasta
all right pasta and noodles and
everybody can just go and
buy some pasta and buy some noodles and
just take it off the shelf and
cook up some kind of pasta dish but if
you do that you're kind of missing out i
mean i do it
um i do it a lot but the difference
between
store-bought pre-made pasta and a
homemade pasta
a handmade pasta is like the same
difference between
a store-bought corn tortilla shell and a
handmade
corn tortilla shell there's a big
difference and
i didn't believe it until i tried it
myself
homemade pasta homemade noodles are far
superior
to the dried store-bought noodles and
they're cheap they're pretty cheap
and they can be made by hand under bad
conditions like let's say you're in a
damn survival situation
really all you need is flour and water
maybe a little bit of salt to get a bare
minimum noodle
uh that's what a chinese noodle is
chinese noodle is basically
all-purpose flour maybe with a little
bit of bread flour thrown in it to make
it a little bit more
chewier and then it's kind of flattened
out with a roller
cut into strips and then you toss some
more
um flour over it
and then fry it let it sit there for a
little bit and then fry it
good and that's all that is all right
now uh
a a european noodle is a little bit
different it's
it's uh all-purpose flour maybe some
bread flour if you have that
i always like to use high gluten bread
flour if you can get it
it's just flour with eggs a tablespoon
and the ratio is like this for every two
cups of flour
it's three eggs and then one tablespoon
of water
and one table excuse me one tablespoon
of oil like olive oil
and then um one two teaspoon of salt
and you fold it together and make those
noodles so you can make it
in an emergency and you can actually you
know this is the ultimate poor people
food
the ultimate poor people food all you
got is flour maybe a chicken outback
that's laying eggs
okay you can make a noodle like that all
right and yet
noodles and and pasta are some of the
most yummy things ever yeah
and very filling very filling very high
in carbohydrate they're very low in
nutrition though
yeah so you have to eat something else
with it
yeah you know and that's really where
where the whole sauce thing came in
although american say like amer italian
american pasta dishes are very heavy in
sauce compared to
a real authentic italian pasta dish
there just might have some olive oil
some
maybe some fresh basil on it
and maybe uh some salted fish or some
octopus or some squid just you know a
lot of times the seafood
honestly i kind of i kind of like it
just like that yeah i mean i like i like
pasta with pretty much anything on it
right
if it just has olive oil and basil i'll
totally eat it just like that
yeah now to make making
us a little easier you want to get
something like this this is a pasta
maker
and normally they have a handle right
here and you just take a bowl of pasta
she take a wad of pasta they come with
instructions and then you hand crank it
and it'll come out through the bottom
and um you can
set how thick you want the new noodles
by turning this
um knob and like i said they come with
instructions when you buy one to give
you kind of a
general overview this one also came with
like a c-clamp so you can tighten it to
the edge of a table
i really found you don't need and you
don't need to though
what what you need that for is if you're
going to attach
electro motor to it because you can
attach electric motor to these and just
drop pasta
through the top and it'll sit there and
it'll squirt it out the bottom and the
thickness that you need
you said squirt squirt it out yeah it'll
press it out
and um some of the little attachments
some of them were little attachments
that'll uh actually slice it on its way
out
i haven't used this one in a while when
it's fully rigged up um
i found personally that spending the
extra money for the
electric one the electric motor is not
real
it's not really worth it i don't think
hand cranking it
in normal home amounts is fine
that's what most people are going to be
doing anyway and honestly i've seen the
hand crank ones for
forty fifty dollars it's not a high-end
one but it'll
kind of like do the job and they'll come
with different um
different uh little attachments and
sometimes little selections so it
it'll cut it out like fettuccine or
it'll cut it out like linguine
or uh angel hair pasta it'll cut it to
that
uh you know what they call it that width
or it doesn't cut it at all
and then you can have it like um lasagna
okay now if you're making noodles
be it european noodles or chinese
noodles
not only is it uh bowls of pasta and
lasagna
it's also um you can do things like
pastel
which is a chinese brazilian chinese
inspired
fritters i guess you could say it's just
a
flat two flat pieces of wonton noodles
with some
cheese and some meat in the middle
pressed together and deep fried real
quick
yeah it's kind of like a deep fried meat
and cheese pie yeah it's real nice
they're real light and airy uh you can
do that or you can um
just um make a straight wonton wrapper
and then just roll up your
egg roll mix in the middle roll it up
and deep fry
just like that so don't it's going to be
kind of a short
show today and then we'll just talk
freely about this maybe i'll answer some
questions
i just wanted to bring it to light
that noodles are very easy to make very
easy to make
and they're they're delicious they're
better homemade than they are
store-bought
um as long as you do the prep work and
pre-make them
so you have some when it comes time to
actually do the preparation it's very
easy to work with but just like
everything else got to plan ahead
you know like yesterday i was soaking
chickpeas
because i was going to make hummus i got
some hummus made today it's beautiful
and garlic hummus i'm going to have some
of that after yeah so
if you're a home cook or a professional
cook or whatever you you have good
habits
you're always doing prep work you're
preparing for something you're going to
make a couple days from now you're
always planning ahead
so you just got to think that way and
one of the things that you might want to
prep ahead
would be to make pasta because once you
got pasta made
especially if it's italian style pasta
you might want to hang it
because you know like in a in a closet
or inside a refrigerator maybe
you can hang it off of a little rack
kind of let it dry out a little bit
that or you can cook it directly but i
like i like to dry it out a little bit
yeah we would used to hang it in the
pantry yeah hang it in the pantry a
little bit and then
let dry out then you can fold it and put
it in a ziplock bag and put it in the
refrigerator
and it'll keep for days and days not it
won't keep for too long it will start to
spoil
well yeah anything's fresh it's not
going to last that long because you
don't put all the preservatives right
right which like i said preservatives
kind of a double-edged sword
i wanted to say you know what's really
interesting is that
as easy as pasta is to make i mean i
know it's a pain in the ass and you get
a plan ahead and [ __ ] like that and some
people don't want to do that i get that
and it's really really easy and cheap to
get the dried pasta yeah do you notice
when i was first
watching some of the gordon ramsay shows
like uh hell's kitchen and stuff
i was actually surprised that they used
just dried pasta like for their lobster
or linguine or whatever the hell
like whatever the dish is i was like you
would think
that he's such a stickler for everything
else and doesn't like anything
yeah just like pre-made ingredients
you'd think that he would at least like
have some
have them make pasta for a restaurant
when you're dealing with large volume
sitting around making pasta that's
that's a [ __ ]
you need a lot of room for that that's
true and you'd have to
you'd need a crew of three guys working
you know
all day all week yeah because you'd need
a lot of
them that's probably why they're doing
that yeah but for a home it's it's it's
it's a lot easier
the the time demands and the space
demands aren't that great it's not
it's not you're going to feed 200 people
you know but um
yeah so just it's very easy to make it's
just like
dealing with any any other kind of dough
you need you need a clean work surface
like an island or a counter
something that's not porous but flat and
you just throw
make sure it's clean and dry real dry
throw two cups of flour in there
make a an indentation in the center of
it
crack three eggs and throw that in the
middle throw a little
uh a tablespoon of olive oil in there
maybe about a teaspoon of
salt and then just start mixing it with
your fingers
in the center of that volcano and absorb
all that
flour and then just start rolling it out
and folding it on itself
put some oil on your hands if it starts
sticking put some oil on the
surface if it starts sticking and then
you just make it into a ball
and you can throw it into your little
pasta maker and it'll
squeeze it out as as noodles if you
don't have that you can roll it out by
hand
with a just like a regular rolling pin
and then take a kitchen knife and cut it
and fold it over and cut it again some
more
now to keep it from sticking onto each
other you might want to
flour it down as like a lubricant so it
doesn't stick with soap you could cut it
with a with with a with a kitchen knife
too
and then just make a hand cut and you
can make any shape you want
if you want to make it squares you can
make them squares
and then drop ravioli filling in each
one and fold it up make a ravioli or a
cannelloni or something you know or you
can make bow ties make whatever you want
with it
you want to get fancy yeah but i
recommend starting off with just regular
flat noodles like for a lasagna that'd
be the easiest
okay and then start working with make
making fettuccine or some kind of
linguine
uh which is you know like a spaghetti
pasta um
work with the simple [ __ ] first and then
once you get it down you can move on to
the
more more complicated stuff like look at
a video and see how you fold a
tortellini
you know there's a way you'd fold it to
fold it in on itself and it's like a
little
wrapped up little it looks like
it looks like a little butt pillow like
you sit on if you have hemorrhoids it
kind of kind of like that
kind of look like a wedding ring kind of
looks like
i like it and or you can make raviolis
which that's two sheets
putting one on top of the other and just
with the filling have you ever made the
tortilla
with a fork on the outside what's that
have we ever made total did we make
not here i've made it in restaurant
though yeah i don't think we ever made
it here we made
we've made uh lasagna noodles we've made
fettuccine noodles we've made raviolis
yeah now when you're dealing with
italian pasta you can also
flavor it with tomato paste there's a
way you can take tomato paste and mix it
in with a little bit of water
or you can fold that into and or
blended spinach to make it green there's
a bunch of different ways you can just
look up the recipes
but start simple and then work from
there
and it's a good skill to have it's a
good
survival home skill if you're ever
caught between a rock and a hard place
and all you have a flower water you can
make noodles
well and honestly i mean pasta it's so
versatile but
i think if you're gonna have a dish
that's just it's
really pasta forward like that's kind of
the star of it then it kind of needs to
be homemade
i think the fact that in so many
restaurants i guess you know
yes there's the cost-effective thing of
using the dried out pasta
but also because they're putting so much
stuff into it that the pasta is not
really the star of the show i guess it's
just kind of like the canvas that
they're
putting sauces and various proteins and
stuff on but if you're gonna just
make something simple that just has like
you said just like olive oil or
basil or whatever on it then i think
it's way better like to have the
homemade one i will say that i'm not
sure about other countries but
i'm sure you can get in other countries
too but probably a different brand
there is um in the refrigerated section
the grocery store there's what the [ __ ]
is the name of that brand
with tony or something like that but it
comes in like a little packet it's kind
it's a little bit expensive
but um it's kind of like handmade pasta
yeah
you know and it's in the refrigerated
section you have to use it like in a day
or two because it'll go bad
but um that would approximate like a
homemade if you really don't want to if
you want
homemade pasta you don't want to make it
that's like that's like pretty good it's
pretty close saundra says tom
always prepares for armageddon yeah
food is apocalyptic food food always
came from
food came from an apocalypse it was
people in shacks
out in the country trying to survive on
their own that was that was where food
came from
because what i mean if you think about
it everybody got to eat
every day yeah you know what i mean or
you know real primitive food is you
walking around with a damn bag catching
[ __ ] trying to make a fire and cooking
it
being like whips i could eat that yeah
yeah that's that's
real apocalypse food right there so
cooking cooking catching food preparing
food
um growing food are all uh essential
human skills if you can't do that
then you just [ __ ] suck you're you're
you're urban or your suburban
and if [ __ ] ever goes south [ __ ]
electricity goes away and [ __ ]
humanity goes away it's the [ __ ] mad
max you gonna die
you gonna die you're gonna be like
sitting around eating yeah
even though me i'm gonna be out there
[ __ ] rifles will running shot lines
you know if i see them i like that then
they're bad i'm gonna eat those people
you know it's just some excess meat
isn't that [ __ ]
you heard it here first yeah that's
great mechanical
eat even eat that's what they did back
then
there's all kinds of signs of
cannibalism from from during primitive
ages you just didn't
let enemy bodies waste away you you get
you shared that well like i said i kind
of feel like in a situation like that
yeah it's just kind of like why would
you that's all that food i mean that's
200 pounds of beet why would you throw
that out
i could throw that away i mean [ __ ] you
can even like make use the bones and
yeah make soup and [ __ ] like that yeah
with cannibal tips that'll be the next
food show yeah
how to prepare human meat all that all
that chrome mania
all those chromatin neanderthal all
those [ __ ]
you know um all those campfires from a
homo erectus period that they dug up all
those
humanoid bones that were found had all
been cooked
the bones had been cooked so they're
telling you what they're doing that says
tool marks on them where they were
cutting meat off of them you know after
they were cooked so
you know yeah they you didn't waste
anything only rich people weigh [ __ ]
and uh post-apocalyptic uh you're not
rich
you just eat it's bum skills
bum skills they're like bums bums have
no problem
they're like cockroaches if society were
to collapse you'd still see bombs
they'd be doing fine oh yeah yeah well
they're getting kind of cold
you know but they probably well it
depends you know they're used to rough
living
uh mosquitoes eat them up you know it
depends on how bummy they are
if they if they if they require that
somehow bummy that yeah
if their whole life is about finding
listerine and drinking listerine and
[ __ ] like that then no they're not going
to make it
yeah let's drink something
that's what's like really funny it's
like i think you think that like other
people are begging you going yeah
no they don't you do it all by yourself
if you if you go back and like look at
the history thing i think you will find
that it's normally you going up above
these stations
not all not always but i want to talk
about it you know what i'm talking about
no sandra german and she eats peanut
butter i got her eating peanut butter
that's a peanut butter eaten german
putting
putting slices of the apple in the
peanut butter
did you make those uh did you make those
peanut butter cookies with the damn
nutella
peanut butter fudge oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
all right and then we got
um sleeves and cheese says tommy's to
make a homemade buttermilk biscuit and
gravy show
oh i just made that just a couple days
back yes you did i
forgot about that yeah a few days ago we
met we didn't make them for breakfast
though i don't think we made it for
dinner right now i make what's called
country gravy or also known as um pepper
gravy
which is a white gravy with um uh
american sausage crumbled up sausage in
it with the
black peppercorns in it it's pork
sausage yeah pork sausage and
peppercorns yeah you pour that over
biscuits but i use bisquick drop
biscuits you can make buttermilk too but
buttermilk for rich people bro
buttermilk
you have to make i'll make it out of
neato yeah
just the cheapest milk you can get you
know just you're trying to make it
fast and uh if you make it well and
simple then uh
and you do it right you don't need real
fancy other
uh components but buttermilk is good
it's real good
it's just the chances of you having
buttermilk on hand
when you want that dish pretty slim
you'd have to plan for it
i mean we hardly ever buy buttermilk
yeah hardly ever buy it well you can't
now
you can make butter if you don't have
buttermilk can't you just do
in it like x amount of milk and so much
like what the [ __ ] you put in it you
could probably put vinegar
i don't remember i wouldn't [ __ ] with it
i don't remember what it is but um
well the thing is we don't usually have
milk in the house either we have
powdered milk
yeah but when when it's like [ __ ] that
we're drinking like right here like this
iced coffee right here that's almond
milk no that's milk oh is it i had some
okay
i thought i didn't even think we had no
a lot of times it is almond milk
i like almond milk is actually a little
more healthier for you than
than cow milk but um sometimes there's
some
cert there are certain things that
you're going to want to do you want cow
milk for that
i love cow milk i love it it's just that
it matters real heavy in calories it's
high in kids it is very fattening yeah
and it's like i had to kind of stop
drinking it because i grew up
drinking a lot of it and uh you know
it's it's not good for your uh
cholesterol squeezing cheese says if i
was gay i'd love
tom for a husband earlier because i cook
[ __ ]
i'll get your ass fat you know it's a
constant war against fat
it is yeah well because everything you
make is so good
yeah i want a lot of it and we just
can't like yeah i mean
and you have a tendency to make a lot of
something
yeah it's a problem because you know
because you know we go to sam's and it's
like every couple months we spend three
or four hundred dollars and like
all this food and we have to eat it yeah
you know and then it'll be something
like like yesterday or the day before
like he made this huge pot of
like curry and it was really really good
and i had like a little bowl and then i
had a little bowl later
but then like the next day he's like
well i'm sick of curry already so he
makes like another thing
so then sometimes at the end of the week
we have like leftovers like all this
other stuff and we have to eat it all
you're making all kinds of pasta jokes
i'm trying to catch up with what
everybody's talking i know i saw all the
pasta jokes that everybody was like
groaning about
honestly if that that's the thing like
we make a lot of
you know we make a lot of indian dishes
we make a lot of asian dishes and stuff
and it's like a lot of times
because you prefer rice usually with
those kind of dishes i prefer noodles
i mean all most of the stuff like thai
stuff you make or anything like that
i mean if it's a choice between noodles
and rice i'm gonna take noodles pretty
much every time
yeah um and i [ __ ] i really have to
stop myself from eating pasta like every
[ __ ] day
i'm laughing here sandra says i'm in my
late 40s and i still haven't locked
lost tris lost electricity in a single
time in my whole life
wow that's made in germany man yeah
i've yeah we've lost it lots of times
well because it's florida and we have
thunderstorms all the time and like i
said hurricanes i've
i've been without power for eight nine
days uh after a hurricane
yeah when when hurricane katrina hit in
louisiana man there were certain air
there were certain areas of the new
orleans area
or new orleans area with uh out of power
for uh
two months yeah i remember being out for
tens of thousands and tens of thousands
of people died
it was [ __ ] it was a disaster
flooding got got a lot of people so
you're in an area where the geography
and the weather is
predictable here it's predictable it's
going to [ __ ] you
you can predict it every time the
weather is going pretty much uh
once summer comes yeah you can like you
can bet on it between 3 and 5
p.m every day it's gonna be a real bad
thunderstorm like pretty much every
single day
yeah and your power is maybe gonna go
out yeah and uh
uh i can't imagine never losing have
never lose you know
if you've never lost power you don't
know what real life is really like
real life [ __ ] sucks [ __ ] hot
really hot you can't do anything
you can't do anything that requires
electricity and you do you do a lot of
things that need
electricity you don't realize it well
yeah it's like we're so used to having
it
that it's just kind of like when you
don't have it you're just kind of like
you're like whoa how many times how many
times like that the one hurricane
that we went through together because i
thought when my power was out for eight
or nine days that time that was when i
was
like still living in daytona but ours
went out for
a couple of days yeah and um every
single time still
every single time i would get up and go
in the pitch dark ass
bathroom and i would and i would always
click the [ __ ] video i'm so like even
though i know the [ __ ] power's off
oh yeah yeah now a couple years back i
we did the right thing and we bought a
really good generator got a honda
generator in there what's it called a
black max i think it's called yeah i
think it's what it's called generator
and it can run two refrigerators and at
least three
wall mounted um uh or some window
mounted uh
air conditioners because you can't
survive in florida without air
conditioning
your your house will just mildew it will
rot well yeah we talked about that
before and when and when our power was
out for a couple days before like that
we had to
well we had stocked up because you know
we know the storm's coming so we had
like a bunch of ice
yeah and uh we had you know made a bunch
of ice and we put ice in the bathtub
yeah and we had to like change out like
when we were trying to sleep
yeah we had to like change out you go
lay in the ice bath
for a little while for a little while
that all lay at the eyes about that
bats have to cool off so yeah that was
before we had the
generator the new generator had the old
generator before the old generator
wasn't strong enough to run everything
yeah you can only run i mean even now
it's like
you know there's cables all over the
house we can run we have a couple of
window
ac units which aren't ideal but if
you're just staying in one room it's
fine
and uh the two fridges because you don't
want all your [ __ ] food to go bad
they got it they got a a thing that i
that i can buy for about 1500
and a special license they'll come and
they'll hook up a
an outlet on the outside of the house
and allow me to plug the generator into
the house
and it'll run the central's heating and
air yeah we were thinking about that
yeah it's kind of expensive though
yeah it's expensive but it's got to be
inspected and everything because they
don't want people burning houses and the
thing about
where we do that i mean where we live
now though it's like they're usually
pretty good about getting the power back
on in a reasonable amount of time
yeah um you know if you lived in like a
much more built up area
or you know something like that i don't
feel like
sondra was asking if our cables are
above or below the ground
it depends where you are um somewhere
cables
yeah they're below yeah all right they
are
it's just you know we had a we had a
couple transformers blow
yeah you know like i think last time
yeah lightning strikes right behind the
house over and over again all the time
actually we were outside one time and
lightning hit the fence yeah on
on the house like on the other side of
ours yeah that was something else it was
like it was just like
like right there and i was just like
well and
haven't had an infantry background and
been on [ __ ] live fire artillery
ranges that you know 105 millimeter
howitzer and 155 millimeter long range
artillery
and some of that stuff we were pretty
close to like you know 500 meters away
when that 155 it hit
it was louder louder than a 155
millimeter artillery shell
boom it was so bright that it lit up the
inside of the damn house
yeah and there's like a white flash
inside the house
you felt the shock wave felt the whole
house just go boom yeah
didn't blast any windows out but it was
it was just right it felt like it could
have
yeah i mean it was actually the one time
that last bad hurricane we had a couple
years back
i think me and you and pookie we went
and slept in the um
walk-in closet yeah because that one
only has like two tiny little high up
windows i was like i don't even want to
be anywhere near the [ __ ] sliding
glass door in case that glass blows
out um because you know we didn't like
some people like a lot you know newer
places and stuff a lot of them have
hurricane shutters like but you have to
go out there and put them on
yeah you know which is a pain in there
so if some people put tape over the
windows i don't think that does much
it's underneath the ground in certain
areas but in other areas it's running
across power poles outside the road
where they can get it
yeah and there's transformers there and
it'll
uh those transporters will get hit by
lightning just explode
yeah we've seen it happen so yeah but
the uh
once it gets into the in into the
housing complex it's all underground
yeah yeah but yeah it's just you know
but
it's it's just bad it's bad yeah but
yeah i remember us like i said sleeping
in the [ __ ]
walk-in closet yeah but you know just on
the floor
if you're if you're into this at the
door if you're in the united states and
you're in the south you're just
you just have to be ready for the fall
of civilization at any moment
it's going to be a hurricane or
a tornado flooding or yeah which is bad
enough i mean [ __ ] man
right and that and it happens i mean
particularly in florida
uh you know hurricane season is june 1st
to november 30th
right um with september and october
being the worst
and it rains every day it's like the
korean monsoon season
it's very similar and in the summer it
pretty much rains every afternoon and
we're talking like bad bad thunderstorms
like they don't usually last all that
long about an hour
but sometimes they're sometimes it's so
heavy that it's just like black out like
if you're on the road you can't
see anything and it's just like heat
rain
and then steam yeah and then more heat
and then rain and then steam over and
over and over again every day
yeah pretty much every day for the day
for the dead of the summer it's not like
that the rest of the year it's just like
we have like a monsoon season basically
and during that time hurricanes and
tornadoes
yeah and flooding and flooding [ __ ] man
there's
alligators well yeah because they're
running from one pond to the next
especially they must get so excited when
it floods because they're like whoo it's
like now there's now and i don't have to
go across the ground i can just swim
over here just driving down the street
you see a turtle four feet five feet
diameter
big what are you doing there flat
big angry looking face it [ __ ] bite
your hand off at the wrist
big ol snapping turtles gigantic look
like camera
yeah like with that camera yeah like
little mini cameras
and when i saw that otter the other day
on the path yeah that's a big ass otter
yep
and then you're just walking down the
middle of your thing and you have four
or five
[ __ ] cranes they're bigger than you
or some of them are five feet tall walk
right up to you and start begging for
food
follow your home and then knock on your
windows and your doors
trying to get you to come out and feed
them they're called sand hill cranes
yeah they're crazy don't feed them don't
feed them because they'll never go away
yeah you're not back every day they
really tell you i made the mistake of
feeding them and they were coming back
those [ __ ] once or twice a week for
like about a month
and they told all their friends all
their friends more of them were showing
up
and if you don't go out back to feed
them then they'll walk up your sliding
glass door and just go
hey you know you're in there and you
like get out of here and you spray them
with water
and they'll back up about 20 feet and
then when you turn your back on them
they run right back up to them
they just they don't take no for an
answer especially if they got young with
them they're like feed this baby
yeah feed this baby it's like come on
you useless [ __ ] yeah
you fed us before yeah oracle said was
it the kind of big-ass otter from the t
king picture book yes very similar it
was actually
quite large like it was almost like dog
size but yeah you remember
that picture and the bears yeah yeah if
some of you guys saw i posted it on
uh did i post it on facebook or maybe
and maybe instagram
but remember that one time like it was
four sandhill cranes and they came
up our driveway yeah and i was like it
was morning and i was like walking by
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and i looked
out the glass so the front door there
was four of them just like sitting there
and going like that like looking at
the [ __ ] they're standing on the truck
and i was like what the [ __ ] or you just
come home late at night and there's a
[ __ ] a bear bigger than a man
sitting there in your driveway yeah
sitting on his ass and then he sees a
little [ __ ] and he rolls
rolls over size of sasquatch we were
driving one time and a bear across the
street right in front of me and this
this is just up the street here and it
was during the day where did nighttime
walked into the neighbors [ __ ] up
their garage
and looked at the refrigerator and i
went hey bear and that bear turn around
get away get it right in that fridge and
then
bear put it put his head down put his
tail between his legs and ran
because some of them can open fridges
they can open the door they've figured
it out
can open up a car door yeah i've seen
them open cars open up windows they'll
open up
doors to houses and go in the
refrigerator and tear up the inside of
your house
they're looking for a picnic bathroom
they got a chip on the video
they know how to open windows they're
not dom nope they know where the food's
at
they got us intelligence similar to a
chimpanzee yeah
chimpanzee dog about in between well
that's why we had to they
they gave us like the county gave us all
these new garbage cans that have this
like complicated [ __ ] trigger system
on it so that the bear can't open it
because that's what bears would do they
would come and go
yeah they would look in there and be
like hey what you got in here and like
tip them all over all over the street
so you know um yeah so did you have
anything else you wanted to say about
any food sandra says that everything in
australia is trying to kill you but
the american south is kind of like that
too yeah it's we don't have as much
poisonous stuff
we do have poisonous stuff yeah we have
some like venomous
moccasins snakes snakes and coral snakes
coral snakes rattlesnakes
yeah but they're not they're not as
deadly as some of the australian stuff
and we don't have that we have black
widow spiders
and brown recluse spiders you know you
know when my brother was a kid
he got bit on the knee by a brown
recluse he didn't die
but he got blood poisoning like it went
his knee
swelled up like really big and then like
you could see the poison like going up
his thigh
and then he had to go to the hospital
and he had to walk with a cane for a
little while
most of the poisonous stuff we have will
[ __ ] you up but not kill you though
yeah even a rattlesnake will really [ __ ]
you up but it probably wouldn't kill you
but you might lose a limb without
treatment a lot of people don't realize
that they think you just get by
bit by the rattlesnake oh you're gonna
be all right oh and it's fine it's gonna
be fine no
it eats a big [ __ ] hole yeah and uh
that hole might expose bone
which means that they'd have to
eventually amputate you get those it's
bad yeah
well and that's what i mean like my
brother got bit by a brown recluse
spider which doesn't sound like a big
deal but if he hadn't gone to the
doctors it was getting he got blood
poisoning
yeah so it's like if you don't go to the
doctor and like get something done about
it then yeah you put
his leg probably yeah you would probably
lose a leg it doesn't sound like a big
deal but you know
you're right you got to get treated for
that kind of [ __ ] but there's some stuff
in australia in another country that
bites you and you're dead within about
an hour
yeah it's like you can't even get to the
hospital they're just like oh well i'm
[ __ ]
yeah so we don't really have anything
like that uh we have alligators that'll
[ __ ] grab you and take you underneath
the water and drown you
and then eat you later yeah save you for
a later date they're mostly going out
for kids
yeah mostly little children it's like
that's that's nice
well yeah it's like i said i think did
we talk about on the dark side of disney
show like that alligator that ate that
little boy
in disney at disney yeah it was one of
the disney resorts actually yeah they
closed all that [ __ ] down after that
well i think all they did now is they
put signs up being like hey there's
alligators in here might not want to
like hang out
well i thought that happened at that at
that island place
no it's closed now yeah no this was at
one of the resorts
this was more recently yeah there was an
island where the disney island resort
it's closed i thought it was that one
no i don't think it wasn't that one it's
been closed for about 10 years
i don't think it's that one okay because
i think that happened like more recently
than that
you know what i'm saying lily said it's
all fun and games until someone
loses a leg yeah yeah all right
so uh you have anything else you would
like to add
no no i'm good it was just a basic
overview and a reminder of what's
possible with
fresh pasta you can make noodles out of
near nothing now it's kind of making me
want something
in a survival situation it's very it's
real hard to make flour though
and get your hands on it there might be
something that could act like flour
maybe potato maybe dried potato i don't
know oh yeah can you make like dry and
i don't know i don't know that might be
weird potato noodles
i don't know look that up i'd have to
look into it
like little especially those little
flaked ones like you get like those
instant potatoes or if you could make
like kind of noodles
it wouldn't work it was not good well it
would be kind of
it would be kind of like what's uh fall
apart what are those [ __ ]
um italian gnocchi that's something
enough
it'd be a little bit like that yeah we
might be able to pull off something like
that but yeah
pull off a say a noodle per se yeah you
know like a gnocchi
yeah sandra said as long as they don't
eat pookie they better not eat pokey i
don't want to
alligators eating pokey i don't want i
don't like to think about anything bad
happening to pokey there's only two
little ponds that she can go to i check
them pretty regularly because she goes
down there with the flashlight
there's no alligators on them well the
one that she likes to look at
is too small i think for an alligator
yeah it's only about seven inches
it said seven inches deep in the middle
now there's a big one that's over
like a few houses down and that has a
sign that says there's alligators in it
although i've never seen one in there
turtles in it there's turtles in there
i've seen turtles and ducks and [ __ ]
like that but i don't think i've ever i
haven't seen an alligator in there
nothing can happen to pookie exactly
nothing better happened to pokey
don't scare her i know it's like it's
well it's like it's something i think
about like all the time like i said you
it's funny ever since we got i mean you
know
i i was always kind of bothered by like
you know animals getting [ __ ] up in
movies
but ever since we got pookie it's like i
can hardly even watch it like that
anymore like i said i don't give a [ __ ]
what happens to people in movies but
yeah
leave the kitties alone yeah but it's
funny you know you
germany never losing power that's that's
amazing no it's just common here like i
said
civilization can collapse at any moment
with a pet with it with a heavy storm
and it might collapse anyway there are
places in the united states where
there's no law enforcement you know
even if you had a cell phone to be hours
before a cop ever showed up there
and where i lived in mississippi was
police response time might be about 35
40 minutes
they're like yeah we'll get them yeah
and the town only had one cop
one for the day one for the night and
you know everybody has guns because you
just have to be your own
guard but they're not violent area areas
they're peaceful
people everybody knows one another and
you know they're they're pretty tight
knit communities but they're kind of
spaced out there's no the population
density is [ __ ]
real well yeah everyone's not like all
up in each other
yeah you know what i mean like can you
see somebody hey what's up
hey you know i can't kiss you because
you saw somebody
you know sandra says do you have those
snap turtles yeah yeah
yeah yeah we have those yeah they get
big that's what i was talking about yeah
yeah they have like a it's like a beak
almost like this
they can take a hand off right at the
wrist and the smaller ones can take a
finger off easily yeah because they're
that's what their little beak is for is
for like crunching
see that's why i talked about in some of
the other shows about running trot lines
like people try to fish in a survival
situation it's too much of a waste of
time you just get a nylon
rope and you string it across a pond and
hanging from the rope or little fishing
lines with hooks
you can bait them or you don't even have
to bait them they'll bite just just the
hook
really you know bait helps but i've seen
them just bite hooks
fish are just like what's this oh i'll
just bite it god damn it i'm so dumb
that's a that's an easy way because you
just leave that thing up there and every
day every couple times a day go down
there and just pull them up out of the
water and see if there's any fish on
them
all right the constant fish trap and uh
you know if you're getting
if you get too many fish you can let
them go you know
because too many i can't eat all these
because you would save them for later
you know yeah well that's the easiest
way the second easiest way of catching a
fish in the south is something called
noodling you put a
you put a glove on and you can walk in
certain places until you find a hole
and you go that's a catfish hole and you
dive down in there and freaking reach in
there and if he bites your hand you pull
them out
they can get big real big uh look up
hannah baron
noodling and she's this little southern
girl who can noodle like that
although she does it mostly for video
they let it go and it goes back in the
hole they know where they are
yeah well yeah it would be kind of like
a boring video yeah just wander around
looking forward to
well some of those catfish might be 15
years old they get bigger and bigger and
bigger every year so they know where the
old ones are and again look at this look
at him
you know yeah have you seen some of the
ones that jeremy wade skipped on the
river monsters
[ __ ] [ __ ] those things could swallow
your whole head yeah the problem with
noodling is though is that there's
always a chance when you put your hand
in that hole that it's not going to be a
catfish that it might be a snapping
turtle
so it's like a crap shoot yeah and that
always worried me
you know what i mean it's like how much
do i need you're waiting and getting
real
you're waiting to get bit and then you
go like i hope this isn't gonna be a
turtle
that feels like a catfish yeah pull them
out like that i'll use my left hand just
in case
yeah oh my god but you got a big heavy
uh
canvas or leather glove on well yeah you
would hope
yeah you don't want to just go
bare-handed in case that is a
snap and turn you never know when you're
just like sticking your hand in a random
hole in the woods
yes like just kind of tense up so it's
giving some resistance when you're
biting so you're you know just in case
just in case it's not that sharp beak
you know
some guy that's happened to some guys
have been all right but you better have
that damn glove on
yeah yeah armed asmr asmr says trapping
is underrated for survival everyone
wants to hunt but trapping is better
yeah uh it is but it
i don't like trapping during peace time
it's inhumane oh [ __ ] can't stand it
uh it's unsporting i would rather just
do [ __ ] with the fishing
yeah now if you're gonna trap you can
trap them in cages but not
not snares or [ __ ] leg traps to snap
the leg and they
cue their leg off over the night i hate
that [ __ ]
that's a lot of fur trappers they'll do
that if you're gonna trap them trap them
in a cage so if you don't want that
animal you can let it go
yeah because you never know what you're
gonna get and you're gonna catch [ __ ]
like bobcat
and i don't believe in killing bobcat
the bobcats is a predator
they're not really meant to be eaten for
every one prey animal
and for every 10 prayer animals you're
lucky to have one predator
you know they don't reproduce very
quickly and they're easy to hunt out so
you know let cats go uh anything like
fox or
coyote you let it go there's not that
many of them
yeah i mean there's no reason to kill
something that you're not going to eat
they don't taste good anyway yeah that's
why i don't really like any kind of
trapping
um it's uh it's too it's not selective
now like i said if it's a cage you can
let him out yeah
you know but i don't like any of the
[ __ ] snap traps and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
snares
um yeah that's [ __ ] up yeah and you
don't have to you don't have to trap
and if you're if you're even halfway
decent
and knowledgeable you're never hungry
anyway you're just not
because there's a lot of food out there
it's just that people don't know how to
get it
and it's it's the easiest is trot lining
50 that's totally that's where all the
[ __ ] yeah you know it doesn't
require a lot of effort wants to lie you
don't need any equipment really you
don't need it
no special equipment nothing or um same
thing with
crabbing and you know you just make a
wire basket
and and wire some bait in the bottom of
the basket and throw it in the water and
crabs will go in there
and you know like a couple of times a
day you check it and see if there's any
crabs in there pull them out
you know it's just easy yeah i mean i
used to do that when i was a kid
yeah we had those little ones that were
like yeah like a pyramid just make a
basket out of [ __ ] chicken wire
yep if it can get through the chicken
wire you don't want it it's too small
yeah yeah it's a bunch of easy ways to
do it
it doesn't require any effort really
it's just knowing and a lot of people
don't know
or scared scared to get in the water a
lot of times you want to get in the
water
you know that's real redneck [ __ ] you're
going to get water
for this later you know yeah then you'd
kind of just go hang out
yeah one man could easily feed four or
five people if he knows what he's doing
yeah all right yeah
so we're gonna wrap it up for today
remember to stop by
tomorrow because tomorrow's wednesday
right okay so tomorrow is our 5
p.m party stream
so everybody needs to drop by for that
one
but yeah thanks for dropping by
everybody today have a good rest of your
day
and we will see you guys tomorrow bye